ANKUR KOTWAL: Good day.
My name is Ankur Kotwal.
RICH HYNDMAN: And I'm
Rich Hyndman.
Welcome to "This Week in Android
Development" for
Monday, 2nd of September,
2013.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Something's been
irritating us for a while.
And with Reto away this week,
we're going to fix a bunch of
his spelling mistakes.
RICH HYNDMAN: Try as we may to
remove Reto altogether, he
continues to haunt us.
Last week, Reto showed us how to
analyze transfer profiles.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I have no idea
what that means, but I guess
we should watch the DevByte.
RICH HYNDMAN: Right?
Daniel tried to hold his
fragments together and help
you do so as well.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And in this week's
episodes of DevBytes--
RICH HYNDMAN: No, wait,
wait, wait.
Who's that?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Oh, that
dashing person?
That's Chris Broadfoot.
I don't know who the
other guy is.
RICH HYNDMAN: Nice
T-shirt, anyway.
They're going to be kicking
off a DevByte series on
building better maps apps.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And Reto is going
to be showing us some
more cool Android cartoons with
little to no relevance to
actual coding.
RICH HYNDMAN: Daniel's going
to show us how to perform
cardflip animations from
inside a doughnut.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And Game On is
back again for another episode
to show us how to integrate
controllers with
your Android games.
How did they get away with
it without them so far?
RICH HYNDMAN: It's not
that hard, is it?
And Shazam.
Shazam's been updated with
tablet-optimized layouts and a
great app icon animation.
So check that out.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Excellent.
So that's all for "This Week
in Android Development." Be
sure to check out this week's
DevBytes as well.
And remember, it's our party,
we can do what we want.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's our party,
we can say what we want.